bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono parigi ed oggi siamo
su perdere un braccio simulator visitors
si chiama così questo gioco perché ci
sono i visitatori in sedia a rotelle di
legno senza le scarpe senza le mani
senza i capelli senza il fisico
vabbè quello anch'io agli onestoni game
fi e allora la cosa che volevo dire
ragazze che questo video che in dovrebbe
parlare di alieni non di gente in sedia
a rotelle che non ti volevo offendere
scusa dovremo trovare delle posso dare
uno schiaffo selezione una cassetta e
non è il caso di selezione infatti mi
posso mettere le cassette ok il country
house is my air mag e chieda cosa
ok io vado a fare i compiti va bè
ragazzi allora dovrebbe essere un
videogioco basato sugli alieni qualcosa
mi dice che così però non ne sono
completamente convinto adesso vediamo se
riesco a convincerlo poi succederà è più
il secchia di giocare su un bel gioco
fatto di persone care e cari
c'è un ragno grosso che mi segue ma io
sono entrato quale la casa più piccola
ma dov'è come casa fatta spari è
difficile perdere di vista un coso così
come ho capito cosa devo fare ma
qualcosa mi dice che non deve vedermi
questo affare ci sto presentimento qua e
io non mi farò vedere non ho ben capito
cosa devo fare mar ci sono delle
poltrone maltrattate diciamo no al
maltrattamento le poltrone su casoni
casa non puoi prenderlo in anche volendo
ma comunque non so magari non mi fa
niente va bene non nome non ci proviamo
a ragatzu che dovrei andare a vedere io
da buon essere umano solidale andare a
vedere che cosa è successo
all'elicottero che si è schiantato se ci
sono superstiti ma io me ne sbatto il
birillo allora qui entrano qua dentro io
se c'è qualcosa di decente tipo non ha
padella per difendermi dal dei nemici
forti grazie che adesso sono tutto
difeso da trovare qualche o per questo
questo è meglio
no è una dinamite solo prima che non so
come lanciarla con che sia ragazzi
allora adesso cio la dinamite forte che
non so bene che cosa mi serve però io ci
farei saltare in aria
questo non è della kinder rosso mentre
la dinamite qua due cose fanno che sul
rumore la campanella di scuola e le
bombe è infatti esplosa fate capire cosa
c'è qua dentro prima che non c'è niente
erano niente devo solo fare esplodere
nuovo a ok quindi questo qua è
l'obiettivo del gioco far esplodere alle
uova aiuola l'albero la do la nuova qui
sopra non mi possono beccare non posso
rimanere nella casa sull'albero per il
resto la salve mi scusi lei che che
sicura
che cazzo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no ti prego zio devi fare però bisogno
sentiti mancano i vestiti chi serve mica
una mano e aladino e la sirenetta quale
dei due stati guardando comunque zio nel
menu principale stavi una sedia a
rotelle non sta lì sopra questa sedia
però va beh se chi serve la sedia a
rotelle sta più o meno dove stanno qui
ragni laggiù quindi se vuoi andare buona
fortuna comunque questa prendo io e non
si sa mai che ti serva ufo spot ed in
serie sai tu stavi catalogando questa
cosa tu hai previsto tu hai previsto e
allora cosa hai fatto ti sei tagliato
una mano e ti si tagliato i capelli
è così che si combattono gli alieni
browser ho trovato lascia con cui ti sei
tagliato la mano quindi va bene grazie
ragazzi allora abbiamo un'altra dinamite
dobbiamo far saltare le altre uova che
non ho ben capito dove sono ma non
importa l'importante è che il nostro
amico sia in salvo soprattutto il cazzo
hai delimitata la mappa bastardi e se
provo uscire lo sapevano stato un
binario
ma cosa cazzo ci fa un binario in mezzo
alle parrocchie che cazzo di binario è
scusate eh va beh chemical ways storage
area finisce qua al binario allora che
minchia limina un'altra cassetta una
bomba nucleare con questa mi serve
importante trova ecco la perfetta ho
trovata corri
ahi ahi serva colpito saltata sì però
dobbiamo muoverci allevarci dal bene ok
eravamo a posso mettere le cassette le
cassette top secret
[Musica]
ci sono dei ragni grossi che vogliono
ingrossarsi un cavallo bene top secret
43 c'è il cavallo che non si vuole fare
inglobare dai ragni grossi viene tornato
dentro però sono inglobato lo stesso
perché ci entrano fantastico eh vabbè
l'orgia pure non correte bambini che mi
date fastidio a farci luca allora le
mansioni ter act amaci scritto dove ci
sono le cose a perfetto altro che setta
cassette found cassette in inglese non
lo sapevano tradurrà non hanno scritto
cassette fa che sia harry potter
stavolta la cassetta meno una top secret
tutto al contrario lo prese prima all
ultima poi la terza per la seconda ci
sono degli alieni acen alieno che si
vuole incappare il cavallo sapevo io che
va a sculacciare cavallo benvenuti su
erotici channel del terzo tipo sempre
bello guardare gli alieni che school a
ciano i cavalli sanco ancora qua
questa roba non la vuole anche vista un
osservatore di merda dinamite perfetto e
vabbè quanta ragazzi ho trovato il de
paix cola la cassetta perfetto cassette
found luce nell'armadietto found con c'è
ancora c'è più niente
altra dinamite e basta ha mica potevo
andare subito qua e trovo tutte quante
subito permesso quando si può entrare
fanno esplodere corri adesso subito
cioè che soddisfa cosa devo guardare
l'ultima cassetta cosa vuoi
no non te ne puoi andare il continuo
thank you so much ice ancora basta
perché ci sono i giorni ma [ __ ]
veramente cioè la prima guardavo la
prima cassetta giusto per curiosità a un
ragno che si in groppa al cavallo
insieme a un niente basta ragno che sin
troppo alte ben barka trai avuto sei
brutto mese l'alieno di o mia donna è la
affanculo
vabbè io salgo la scala nel dubbio e
devo far saltare le uova servizio e ma
tu mangi qualcosa o se qua che quelle
cose
carissimo 1
o è morto e non voglio vederlo in piedi
ad allora sei stronzo fatti esplodere il
nuovo in bocca ma che voi che le faccio
escludere subito dentro sa dove sono
cazzo di paribas reim paralizzare a
realizzare il barbaro riparo veloce e
vabbè vabbè lo dico a mamma lo dico a
mamma kidnapped ragazzi miei basta dopo
aver visto tanti cavalli inglobati
ragazzi dire che possono chiudere qui
questo gioco vi ripeto costa 5 euro su
steam meritati è proprio tanto se vi è
piaciuta ragazzi cose che adesso
documento è un bel live the city sky che
ricevi chiaro prossimo video ragazzi